so I'm gonna start the second portion of
the talk so this one is going to be on
secretary problems instead and just
again to give you a heads up the format
of the talk will be similar to the first
half where I am going to show you
complete proofs of things the technical
detail will be roughly comparable for
the first half ok so we already saw
motivation from the first half let me
just remind you of what the secretary
problem is in the model here before I
get started okay so what's gonna happen
is off line every secretary is gonna be
assigned to wait by an adversary this is
unknown to you the secretaries are gonna
be permuted randomly and then online the
secretaries are revealed to you one at a
time
once it's revealed you'll earn their
weight and you have to immediately and
irrevocably decide whether or not to
hire and your goal is to maximize the
probability of selecting the max weight
element ok so just again to show you
this animation of what this might look
like is here the sec the adversary has
assigned some weights and then they're
going to be revealed in some random
order and you're gonna decide to accept
their rejects so say you decide to
reject and then you decide to reject
again and then when you finally decide
to accept you have to do this again
without from learning what's gonna
happen in the future ok so again I'm
just gonna go even quicker straight into
some analysis the first part is going to
be more basic it'll get a little bit
more difficult as we go throughout the
talk ok so let's first try and reason
about on what does the optimal policy
look like so first let's observe that
the optimal policy without loss of
generality only accepts elements that
have the largest weight seen so far ok
so why is this well any element that
isn't the largest so far is clearly not
the largest element of the
you're set so you don't gain anything by
accepting it and maybe if you reject it
you get something in the future okay and
the second observation I want to make is
similar to profit inequalities you can
find the optimal policy using dynamic
programming and backwards induction okay
so let's try and reason through this so
if somehow we make it to the very last
element and it happens to be the largest
so far then of course we should accept
it because it's actually we know it's
the largest element because it's the
last element of the set and we have
nothing to gain by rejecting it okay so
let's go one step back let's say if we
make it to step n minus one and we see
the largest element so far it's FN minus
one what are our two choices we can
either accept it and then as long as the
real largest element isn't coming in the
next step this is actually the largest
element of the entire sequence and that
happens with probability one minus one
over n right so as long as the last
element doesn't happen to come at the
very last step then the if the n minus
first element is the largest so far it
is actually the largest element of the
whole sequence okay so if you accept it
you get the largest element with
probability one minus one over N if you
reject it then you're gonna reach the
last element and that one will be the
largest only if the largest element
winds up arriving at step n which
happens with probability one over n okay
so as long as n is at least two it's at
least as good to accept and minus 1
instead of reject okay and we can repeat
this reasoning further backwards and say
if we make it two step I and we see the
largest element so far what are our
choices we can accept it and then we get
the largest element with probability I
over N so why is this so as long as the
largest element comes in the first I
steps then conditioned on I being the
largest element so far it is actually
the largest element of the whole
sequence okay or we can reject it
and then we don't necessarily get the
largest element with probability and
minus I over N because maybe the optimal
policy can't guarantee to get the
largest element just because it shows up
later but let's just to note this by F
of I n to be the probability that the
optimal policy selects the largest
element conditioned on starting from
step I plus one okay so these are
probabilities that we can compute using
backwards induction and we should accept
element I if and only if I / n is larger
than F of I n okay so all this
observation is saying is that you can
use dynamic programming to find the
optimal policy and I left part of the
proof up here because I want to do some
reasoning about these probabilities F of
I n ok so the next observation is that
if I is less than J then I claim that F
of I n is at least as large as f of J n
okay so let's prove this so one policy
that I can use starting from I plus one
is I could just reject everything until
I reach step J plus one and then run the
optimal policy starting from J plus one
okay and this will succeed with exactly
probability F of J n but maybe there's
something better I can do starting from
I plus one then decide ahead of time I'm
gonna reach J plus one okay so this
means just to parse what this means is
it for earlier indices you are less over
earlier indices you are more likely to
find the optimal element after it then
you are to find the optimal element
after a later index so this shouldn't do
it if we make some sense okay and the
last observation I want to make and this
is a the key one that I'm going to keep
after this slide is that now we can say
much more about the optimal policy than
just that we can find it by solving a
dynamic program that the optimal policy
has this following simple format it's
going to set some cut-off time T it will
reject everything before time T and it
will accept any element after T if and
only if it's the highest element we saw
so far
okay so why is this so we learned from
observation too that the optimal policy
accepts eye if and only if I over n
exceeds this F of I n that we computed
and it's the highest so far okay so now
if I is less than J and the optimal
policy would accept I conditioned on
being the highest so far we get the
following chain of inequalities using
observation 3 so J over N is certainly
larger than I over N because the optimal
policy would accept I I over N is at
least as large as F of I N and by
observation 3 F of I n is at least as
large as F of Jan ok so in the outer to
directly say that the optimal policy
would also accept J if it was a highest
so far so this means that whatever the
minimum time step is that the optimal
policy would accept the high condition
on being the highest so far it will also
accept anything after I condition on
being the highest so far okay so this is
the only observation I want to keep from
the previous slide and now I want to
find what is the optimal choice of
cutoff so what is the optimal policy ok
so before we do that I want to give you
a suboptimal choice of a threshold that
uh basically you know it's as a cute
simple proof and the idea will actually
be useful later ok so I claim that there
is a choice of cut-offs that guarantees
selecting the max weight element with
probability at least 1/4 ok so what is
that policy so let me read this a bullet
first so really what you would like to
do is you would like to have every
element come before the cutoff with
probability 1/2 and after the cutoff
with probability 1/2 and you'd like this
to be independent of where the other
elements wind up ok so how can you
simulate this by choosing a cutoff well
you can choose a random cut off from the
binomial distribution and 1/2 so
formally I mean flip and coins that are
unbiased and the number of heads set
that to be your random cutoff
okay and this has the property that
every element is before the cutoff with
probability 1/2
independent of the other ones because
our ordering is uniformly at random okay
so now let's reason that if the highest
element comes after our cutoff and the
second highest element comes before the
cutoff
we will definitely select the highest
element so why is this the second
highest element comes before the cutoff
so it will definitely be rejected
everything that comes before it will
also be rejected and anything that comes
after it has to be larger than the
second highest element to be accepted
and only the highest element is so we
will definitely have room for the
highest element and when the highest
element comes it will be after the
cutoff so we will choose to accept it
okay and the above occurs with
probability 1/4 exactly because the
highest element comes after T with
probability 1/2 and independently the
second highest comes before T ok so this
is just a cue proof that you can get 1/4
this isn't optimal and actually the best
you can do is due to a Seminole theorem
of Dinkin which shows that the optimal
policy gets the highest element with
probability roughly 1 over e ok so let
me prove this and there's gonna be one
lemma and one corollary of this lemma ok
so what we'd like to do is um figure out
first for any time step little T what is
the probability that we have not
accepted something before we reach time
step little T okay and I'm claiming that
if we use cutoff big T that this is
exactly the probability it's the min of
our cutoff over t + 1
okay so let's prove this so certainly if
little T is less than our cutoff we will
definitely reach time T because we won't
accept anything before the cutoff if
instead little T is after the cutoff
then we reach it if and only if no
element between our cutoff and T is the
highest so far so if and only if we
don't accept anything before we get
there and let's see about what has to
happen for this condition
okay so I claimed this happens if and
only if the highest element from the
first tee time steps also arrives before
the cutoff okay so let's see why that's
the case let's say X is the highest
element from the first tee time steps if
it happens to come after the cutoff it
will definitely be accepted okay so
because it's the highest element from
the first little tee time steps it's
definitely the highest that has been
seen so far when it arrives so what will
be accepted if instead it arrives before
the cutoff it will definitely be
rejected everything that came before it
will be rejected and everything that
comes in between the cutoff and little
tee can't be accepted because they all
have weight less than X okay so we have
so we're each time step little T if and
only if X arrives before Big T and this
probability is exactly the cutoff over
little T okay because this is exact it's
just it's just a function of the
ordering of the elements that come
before T it has nothing to do with what
those elements actually are which
element is arriving at T it doesn't
matter it's just a property of how
they're ordered okay and the ordering is
uniformly at random
okay so that's dilemma so what's the
corollary is it now we can compute for
any cut off time what is the probability
that it selects the max weight element
okay and I claim it's exactly this sum
which is just summing over every time
step that the highest element might
arrive at and possibly be accepted of
this term which is just a cut off over a
little TN okay so let's prove this so
the probability that we select the max
weight element just sums over every time
step the probability that the highest
element arrives at that time step and is
selected okay if little T is less than
our cutoff and the highest element
arrives at time T it definitely isn't
selected so this term will be zero if
instead it arrives after the cutoff then
it's selected if and only if we have not
accepted something before reaching there
so if and only if we reach that time
step okay but we worked out in dilemma
exactly what this probability is so okay
bright so we worked out exactly what
that probability is and now we just need
to observe that this is independent of
whether or not the highest element
arrives at that time step because again
whether or not we reach time T is only a
property of how the elements before time
T are ordered it is not a property of
what those elements actually are okay so
this means that the probability that we
select the highest element is exactly
what we said it just sums over every
time step this one over N is the
probability that the highest element
arrives at time step T and this big T
over little T is from here the
probability that we actually reach that
cutoff okay so this is the corollary and
with these two we can now prove the
theorem okay and basically all we're
gonna do is we're gonna try and optimize
this sum over all choices of cut-offs
and all that happens here as we observe
that for very large n this sum is
approximately the same as this integral
we can evaluate this integral it happens
to be
the cutoff over n times the log of n
over the cutoff and then we can take a
derivative and find out that it's
maximized at exactly n over E which
gives us a success probability of 1 over
e ok so that's a complete proof there
any questions about this
okay but okay so that's the optimal
policy and this is due to seminal work
of thinkin and I will also just point
out that if instead your game is not to
maximize the probability of selecting
the heaviest element you want to
maximize the expected weight of the
element you get then you can see that
this is also at least the max weight
element over E right because you select
the max weight element with probability
one over E maybe you select something
else the remainder of the time and that
gives you only additional okay so before
I go on so we are gonna go into multiple
choice problems again in this talk
before I do that let me just compare to
the single choice profit inequality so
in both cases there is a simple policy
that gets a constant and optimal
competitive ratio in the secretary
problem we had to do some extra work but
we were able to show that this simple
policy is actually optimal on all
instances okay it's not that it just
gets the optimal competitive ratio it's
actually the optimal policy whereas in
the profit inequalities the simple
policy does get the optimal competitive
ratio but it's not necessarily optimal
on every instance right so the dynamic
program there gave us something more
complex as the optimal policy
okay so that's everything I'm gonna say
about the yep is also tight for the for
the case I mean if you want to maximize
B I mean yeah so it is tight so just
imagine so I mean okay so there are no
distributions right so you don't know
anything so really just imagine that all
the weights are you know like a million
to the I you have no idea you know what
I is or where they start there's really
nothing you can do
yeah that's right so as I'm not claiming
that this is a formal proof but I like
okay so there is a formal proof I just
don't know it and it's not written all
the slides yeah
okay so um and the rest of the talk
again we're gonna look at
multiple-choice secretary problems okay
so what generalize is exactly the same
way is provident apologies let me just
state it to be clear so offline what's
gonna happen is every secretary is gonna
be assigned a weight chosen by an
adversary the adversary in addition
chooses some feasibility constraints
which is which secretaries can you
simultaneously hire and then the
secretaries are permuted randomly online
if the secretaries are revealed one at a
time you it excuse me you interview and
learn their weight you immediately in
irrevocably decide whether or not to
hire and again the game is that you must
maintain your set of hires to be
feasible at all times okay and now when
I'm phrasing it like this I will change
the objective to sound just a little bit
different and we'll say you want to
maximize the expected weight of your
hires okay but just remember there are
no distributions here so the expected
weight is over the randomness in the
permutation well you're always going to
try to compete with the max over all
feasible sets of the sum of weights in
that set okay so you're not competing
what you're trying to compete with is
not a random variable it's it's fixed
because the adversary chooses the
weights and they're fixed there's no
randomness there okay so again this
slide is supposed to serve the same role
as in the previous talk I will leave it
up and talk for a minute or so I'm not
gonna read through any in detail it's
again just to show you that there's been
a lot of recent work from our community
on multiple choice secretary problems
okay so while it's up what we claimed
that me and David parts that trying to
be are introducing the secretary problem
for the auction and I seems I didn't
know that so it's still one of its the
same ratio that for the cake version the
facilities today there's another
application especially self care items
and that is they take early you see
2004's a she
I see and it gets it's the same
competitive ratio we don't get such a
ratio I see okay say that the
application for that one got playable
parts and me easy 2004 okay all right
thanks okay so let me I'll just define
some terms for you these terms actually
aren't going to be used later in the
talk but I figured I should say
something while this slide is up and
these are useful terms to know the
definitions of okay so a transversal may
troy'd is one type of feasibility
constraints where the elements are
left-hand nodes of a bipartite graph and
the set of nodes is feasible if and only
if there exists basically if and only if
it's possible to match every node in
this set to a distinct right-hand node
okay so it's not quite bipartite
matching x' but it's basically one side
of a bipartite matching and it happens
to form a matron
regular mate roid is the following kind
of odd definition so if it is possible
for every field F to represent your
elements as vectors in a vector space
over F such that feasible sets
correspond exactly to linearly
independent subsets then the mate or is
said to be regular okay so these are
special kinds of vector spaces that can
be represented over every field not just
the one not just one okay but again this
is all I'm gonna say about these results
and okay and before I get in so I am
going to prove some results but before I
do that I actually am gonna use a little
bit of terminology from mate roids
throughout this talk everything I'm
going to use is pretty basic and will
fit on this slide but I just need to go
through it first okay so just to remind
you a mate roid is feasibility
constraints that are first downwards
closed and second they have this
augmentation property that whenever two
sets are feasible and one is larger than
the other there exists an element in the
larger one that you can add to the
smaller one that maintains feasibility
okay I'm also going to use this term the
rank of a matrix ax m'm size of
any feasible subset of sorry the rank of
a set is the maximum size of any
feasible subset of s okay and again if
this is a little bit abstract you should
think of vector spaces you would say the
rank of a vector space is the maximum
number of linearly independent vectors
contained in that space okay so with
this feasible sets are exactly the ones
that have their size equal to their rank
and that you can read that from the
definition and we sometimes also use
this term a basis of a set s to be any
subset that is feasible and has size
equal to the rank of s okay and this
term is also drawn from linear algebra
where you would say a basis for a vector
space is exactly the same thing okay
I'll also use this term the span of a
set which is formally all of the
elements such that you could add them to
s without increasing the rank okay and
again you should intuitively think of
vector spaces you would say the span of
vectors is everything you can write as a
linear combination of them and if you
were to add them to this set you would
not make the basis any larger okay and
the last fact I'm going to use is a
theorem from Edmunds I'm not going to
prove this or anything most many of you
probably know this already is that the
greedy algorithm finds the max weight
feasible set in allmate roids okay so
what is the greedy algorithm it means
that if you sort the elements in
decreasing order of weight and you just
run through them and accept any feasible
element this will find you the max
weight basis of any matrix
okay two other facts that are true is
first that it's feasible to accept I
when you go through this if and only if
I is not in the span of the earlier
elements okay so you should think about
this some one example of matrix are a
cyclic sub graphs of a graph and we know
that the greedy algorithm works to find
a min or max weight spanning tree and
you can think of elements being spanned
if you've already if adding them would
form a cycle okay so
again just to try and draw intuition for
this and what this implies is that I is
in the max weight basis if and only if
it is not spanned by elements that are
heavier than it okay so I am going to
use on this terminology and some of
these facts later in the talk okay so
what am I gonna do in the rest of the
talk so I just want to give you a taste
for some of the different techniques
that people use to prove multiple choice
profit inequalities and I'm gonna do it
with these three results and I do want
to point out that I'm not going to use
any like deep or interesting may tree in
this talk there are some results that
use like real may trade Theory
comparable to the kinds of theorems we
have about linear algebra there exist
similar theorems for meit roids
and there are some papers that use them
but these are really going to be more
first principles types arguments and
they're not going to use anything more
than what was on the previous slide okay
so now I'm just going to get in I'm just
going to prove these three results and
that will be the rest of the talk okay
so this is a theorem due to bobby alpha
more like a campaign Kleinberg that
shows that there is an e approximation
for k uniform bate roids okay so what is
the algorithm so when the element at
time step T is processed you're gonna do
the following so if the time step is too
early so if it's less than n over e you
reject it if the current element is not
in the top case so far then reject it
this third condition is a little bit
weird I'll give you some pictures to
explain it is if the previous case
highest element before you arrived after
the cutoff and over e then you also
reject it okay so this is going to seem
this is a little bit of a weird
condition and the intuition for why this
is a good idea comes from the proof so
just hold off on expecting intuition and
let me just at least give you some
pictures to show you what this algorithm
is actually doing okay so here's an
example where K equals 2 and N equals 5
and just to make you know this example
valid for the algorithm pretend that the
cutoff is 2 okay so 5 over E is less
than 2 the cutoff should be 1 I'm
using a cut-off of - okay so what's
gonna happen is when Bulbasaur comes
Bulbasaur's before the cutoff so
Bulbasaur will be rejected by this when
squirtle comes squirtle is before the
cutoff so squirtle will be rejected
when Charmander comes Charmander is
after the cutoff so that's good
Charmander is in the current top - so
far and what is the previous second
highest element that's Bulbasaur
Bulbasaur arrived before the cutoff so
we will accept Charmander okay when
Pikachu comes Pikachu comes after the
cutoff so that's good he is in the top
two so far so that's good and what is
the previous second highest element so
the previous second highest element was
squirtle squirtle came before the cutoff
so we will accept Pikachu now when
Mewtwo comes you too is after the cutoff
it is in the top two so far the previous
second highest element though is
Charmander in Charmander came after the
cutoff so the algorithm will choose to
reject Mewtwo okay so this is one run of
the algorithm I'm just gonna show you
two more pictures to make sure it's
really clear okay so again the first two
elements will always be rejected because
they come before the cutoff any element
after the cutoff so Charmander is in the
top two so far in the previous second
highest element is squirtle so and
squirtle came before the cutoff so we'll
accept Charmander
when Bulbasaur comes it is after the
cutoff but it's not in the highest two
so far so we'll reject
now when you to comes it is in the top
two so far but the previous case highest
element is Charmander
so before Mewtwo came the top two were
Pikachu and Charmander and Charmander
came after the cutoff so this rule will
say reject new - yes we just stopped but
you're not going to accept any one
well the third condition holds no
because so let me see if I can get a new
yeah you can get a new case highest
option that the K minus one highest yes
that's a better yeah yeah I see yeah
good thank you yeah so he said so what
might happen is that currently the case
highest is after the cutoff then a new
element comes that is the new K minus
first highest and maybe the previous K
minus first highest was before the
cutoff so now the caithe highest will
get pushed down to be being before the
cutoff yet thank you okay good and the
last example I wanted to run okay so the
first two bulbous horn you tube will be
rejected there before the cutoff
squirtle comes the current element sorry
it is in the top two so far the previous
second highest was Bulbasaur squirtle
gets accepted
Charmander comes it is in the top two so
far but the previous second highest is
squirtle which was after the cutoff so
Charmander is rejected when Pikachu
comes it is in the top two so far the
previous second highest was Charmander
who came after the cutoff so Pikachu is
also rejected okay
so the algorithm makes sense all that
this is not supposed to give you
intuition as to why the algorithm is
good this is just supposed to show you
what the algorithm is doing that's the
next that's yeah the next thing I'm
going to say so it shouldn't be clear
but it will be now okay okay so the
first observation is that the algorithm
will never accept more than K elements
okay so why is this so let's let s be
the top K elements that arrived before
the cutoff and over E and now we can
kind of see that every element we accept
kicks out one of these elements from
being in the top K so every time we
accept something we can
but uniquely to an element in s and so
this means that we can never accept more
than K elements because we only had K
elements in us to start with okay so
there's a charging argument that says
that we don't accept more than K ok so
that's good so it at least means that
this algorithm is feasible now we need
to show that it gets a good
approximation okay and in the proof of
this proposition it'll become clear why
we wanted to have this weird rule for
accepting and rejecting okay so if I is
in the top K then the true top K so it's
really one of the top K elements it is
definitely in the top K so far when it
arrives so it will always pass the
second test and if it arrives at a time
step after n over e it'll pass the first
test so it gets accepted if and only if
the case highest element from the
previous steps arrived before and over e
okay because it needs to pass the third
test okay and the probability that this
occurs this is very similar to the
reasoning from the one uniform case is
exactly and over I over T right because
excuse me where the K highest element
from the previous steps arrives is only
a property of the ordering of those
elements it doesn't matter what those
elements are it doesn't matter what
element is arriving at time T this is
only a property of how those elements
are ordered and because the ordering is
chosen uniformly at random the
probability that this specific element
happens to fall before the cutoff of n
over E is exactly an ovary over T okay
yes
it should be yes sorry it should be t
minus one that's right so subject to
this being so this should be t minus one
this should be t minus one I'll keep
this one is T okay so now this math is
exactly the same math that we solve for
the one uniform case okay so the
probability that element I is accepted
conditioned on being in the true top K
sums over every index after and over II
the probability that it arrives at this
index which is 1 over N times and over
II over T the probability that it gets
accepted conditioned on arriving at that
index this is again approximated by this
integral and this integrates to exactly
1 over e ok so the whole reason for
using this weird rule was we wanted to
make the math look exactly like the one
uniform case and pick a specific element
and say if this element happens to come
before the cutoff then we got accepted
if it happens to come after the cutoff
then we don't get accepted okay so this
is um I guess I'm just gonna say one
more thing oh sorry
ok so now that we have this observation
in proposition there's just one more
line to finish up the proof basically
the observation guarantees that the
algorithm is feasible and the
proposition guarantees that we get any
approximation okay so this is the whole
proof are there any questions about this
yes if you don't have this condition the
algorithm does work the proof is much
messier so I think this is a without
this line I think was in the original
like ba ba alpha more like a Kleinberg
paper and then they have follow up with
David Kempe that provides this
modification and the proof is much
cleaner so that's why I wanted to
present this one so even though the
algorithm is a little Messier the proof
is like way cleaner to do it this way
he is not tight it's not it's like one
plus order 1 over root K and that is
asymptotically tight so for K so as cake
grows you can do better and better and
better okay
so what I want to point out about this
there is an underlying technique that
might generalize beyond just K uniform
so what happened was we took these
samples to be the max weight feasible
set of elements that came before our
cutoff and we decided that whenever we
accept an element we're going to charge
it to one of the samples and we found
out how to do this in a consistent way
so that no sample is charged twice
excuse me in the samples are charged
consistently to maintain feasibility of
the accepted elements okay so this is a
kind of idea that possibly could
generalize beyond just K uniform eight
roids and that's everything I want to
say about this theorem I'm going to move
on to a new result
okay so the second result I want to show
you is for graphic matrix okay so here
this is a result due to Corolla and Paul
that there's a 2e approximation for
graphic matrix
okay so let me state the algorithm and
again I'll show you in pictures what's
going on so you're going to pick a
random ordering of the nodes offline and
then you're going to define the
following sets for every node V take all
of the edges that have one endpoint and
V and the other endpoint later than V in
the ordering okay and call this a T sub
V and now you just run Dinkins one
uniform algorithm on each piece of V
separately online okay so what does this
look like so here's as an example let's
say that this is the random ordering you
choose the lower nodes come first and
what's going to happen is you're just
gonna take each edge so say this top
edge and you're gonna group it with its
lower endpoint okay and you're gonna do
this you know for many of the edges so
for this one we said it's edges are as
endpoints or three and four let's group
it with three for three and five let's
grip it with three for one and five will
group it with one and we do this
simultaneously for all edges okay so now
for every node we have a collection of
edges and we're just going to run
Dinkins one uniform algorithm on each
set separately okay
this is the the algorithm makes sense I
guess before I start proving anything
all right so first let's also observe
that this algorithm always accepts an
acyclic sub graph so remember the edges
are the elements in a cyclic sub graphs
are feasible
okay so let's approve this so assume for
contradiction that the algorithm somehow
accepts a cycle and let's let V be the
earliest node according to the ordering
that arrives in this cycle okay then V
has two edges in the cycle adjacent to
it and both of these edges have another
endpoint that was later than V in the
ordering so that means that we have two
edges from evie because we defined both
of these edges would have been put in
evie by this definition so this is a
contradiction okay so the algorithm will
definitely never accept a cycle so
that's good and now we want to prove
that it gets a good approximation ratio
edges are arriving online yeah so the
edges are ordered arbitrarily it might
be that you get some edges from node V
and then some other edges from load V
later they're not ordered by notes in
any way whole thing is a completely
random order yeah okay so let's get some
intuition for the algorithm first before
proving that it works okay so if we
happen to get lucky and we choose an
ordering that recursively selects leaves
of the max weight spanning tree then I
claim we would get every edge of the max
weight spanning tree with probability 1
over E okay so in this example let's say
that the green edges are the max weight
spanning tree and we happen to choose
the following ordering ok so what do I
mean when I say it recursively selects
leaves I mean one is a leaf in the max
weight spanning tree two is a leaf once
one and two have been deleted three is
now a leaf of them of what's left and
then four is a leaf and five is a leaf
once three and four have been deleted
okay so if you get lucky and you choose
an ordering like this what happens well
when we put the other edges back and we
look at the partition we get notice that
every green edge is in a different
partition okay so this is kind of like
the dream case because now for each
partition
we get at least the weight of this green
edge over e here we get at least the
weight of this green edge over E and so
on
so right so by summing over each of
these partitions were actually covering
every edge in the max weight spanning
tree with probability at least 1 over E
ok this is what we would love to happen
but we don't know what the max weight
spanning tree is ahead of time so we
can't choose this ordering and at the
point is that we don't lose more than a
factor of 2 by doing this randomly okay
so what's the proof so let's first
observe that the expected reward of the
algorithm is exactly the sum over all
nodes the expected weight of the max
weight element in a V divided by E okay
so this randomness is over the choice of
evie and this is just by saying when you
run Dinkins algorithm you always get the
expected max over E okay so now let's
let V be any leaf in the max weight
spanning tree and let e be the unique
edge in the max weight spanning tree
adjacent to V then we clearly have the
expected max of sorry the expectation of
the max weight edge in evie is at least
W e over 2 because this edge e is in AV
with probability 1/2 okay and we can do
this simultaneously for all leaves and
think about it as once you pick a leaf
you pick this unique edge and then you
remove this edge in this leaf from the
max spanning tree and then you repeat so
now let's say V is a sum node that
became a leaf in the max weight spanning
tree once all the leaves were removed
and EB the unique edge and the max
weight spanning tree adjacent to it then
you can use exactly the same reasoning
and say that the expected max weight
edge in evi is at least
w/e over to okay and okay so now you can
just recursively repeat this reasoning
for all nodes in all edges and
eventually every edge in the max weight
spanning tree is going to be covered by
this reasoning by one node
every node is going to be used here to
cover exhibit most one edge because
whenever it covers an edge it's because
it's the unique edge connecting it as a
leaf and so this implies that when you
sum over all nodes of this expected max
you're going to get every edge is going
to be covered by exactly one of these
nodes by this reasoning and so you get
opt over - yes if you have a node from
which you have many leaves and then
there's a path above and so once I
remove these leaves I mean this Nord
they're very low probability of it's so
so fun of these edges would be incident
on right so so basically what I'm what
I'm arguing is that maybe the expected
max of of edges in that Eevee maybe it's
actually way higher than the weight of
this edge but all I'm claiming is that I
didn't use any of these edges like I
didn't like I covered these edges with
leaves that we're touching them so this
node maybe maybe you do even better
maybe you get whatever the max is of all
the edges that are hanging off of it but
we don't even need that you can pretend
those edges aren't even there you only
get credit from the one left does that
answer yeah okay are there any other
questions about
okay so that's the complete proof so
this algorithm gets you a 2e
approximation and again I want to
highlight what is the underlying
technique that might generalize is we
decided to kind of decide that some
feasible sets even though they are a
cyclic sub-graphs we decided to call
them not feasible
okay so we've restricted the feasibility
constraints but we restricted them in a
way that the new feasible sets were much
simpler okay so they happen to be a
disjoint union of many smaller and
simpler subproblems but we did it in a
consistent way so that any union of
feasible solutions to the simpler
problems is also feasible so that was
the first observation okay so in this
case each subproblem was as simple as
possible it was just a one uniform a
troy'd and i just want to point out that
on many of these recent works follow
this very similar high-level
decomposition approach in the sense that
they restrict what sets are considered
feasible in this principled way but the
decomposition itself is more complex
than this and the subproblems that
result are also more complex than this
but I just want to point out that this
really is this decomposition idea really
does generalize beyond just a graphic
sequence okay so is any way so I'm gonna
move on from this result and do one last
result and wrap ups or any questions
about this
okay so the last result I want to show
you is actually in a slightly different
model called the free order model let me
define for you what this model is it's
not very different
so still offline every secretary has a
weight chosen by an adversary the
adversary chooses feasibility
constraints and you'll notice what's
missing is that the elements are
randomly permute 'add okay so what
happens instead is you choose which
secretary you want to interview one at a
time you learn their weight and then you
immediately an irrevocable decide
whether or not to hire and the rest of
the problem is the same you must hire a
feasible set of secretaries at all times
and your goal is to maximize the
expected weight of the hires okay so I
just want to make a note to convince you
this is not like a cheating version of
the problem that if you restrict this
problem to one uniform eight roids you
get the original secretary problem back
okay so why is that because when you
choose which secretary to interview you
don't know their weight you only know
the element and in the one uniform case
all the elements are a priori identical
so you're basically choosing a random
element that you want to interview okay
okay but that's just supposed to
convince you that this is this is not
like a crazy easy restriction
okay so I'm gonna give one more
definition is the last definition for
the talk and then I will state the
theorem and prove it okay so let's let
them s be any set and say that the
elements are ordered in decreasing order
of weights and let J be the minimum
index such that I is in the span of the
first J elements okay so what I mean by
that is we're gonna start with the
heaviest element in s and go all the way
down by adding each element one at a
time at some point we will span I and
this is where we stop and we'll say that
the weight of the last element we added
is equal to the price of i with respect
to s ok so the definition makes sense so
think of this as so again I'm going to
start with the heaviest element and add
one by one eventually I'm going to span
s the weight of the last element I add
this man s I'm gonna call that its price
okay so some examples is it for K
uniform 8 roids the price of i with
respect to a set s is the K highest
element of s because if I start with one
element I don't span I if I keep adding
I need to have K elements and then as
soon as I have K elements I span I okay
for a graphic may troy'd the price of i
with respect to s is gonna be the min
weight edge on the cycle formed by
adding i to the max weight spanning tree
okay so again the point is when do i
span i i span i when i forms a cycle
what is the last edge that's going to be
added before i have a cycle with i it's
going to be the min weight edge along
this cycle okay in just one observation
that maybe will help with this
definition is that i is in the max
weight basis of s union i if and only if
the weight of i exceeds its price with
respect to s okay so why is this because
if I run the greedy algorithm to find
the max weight basis for s Union I I
will start with the heaviest element and
I will accept everything that is not
spanned so if I get to I before I span I
then I is in the max weight basis
if I get to the element that induces the
price of is before I get to I then I
span I okay and the point is that I get
to I before I get to this element if and
only if the weight of I exceeds its
price okay so this is just some
intuition for this definition and now
with this definition we can state the
theorem and state the algorithm that's
used to prove it okay so this is due to
work of AI Soto in Zen clusen where they
showed that there is a for approximation
for allmate roids in the free order
model okay so what is the algorithm so
let's let this sample set s contain each
element independently with probability
1/2 will process all elements in s first
and reject all of them and then will
process the remaining elements in a
specific order in decreasing order of
their price with respect to s and we'll
accept an element if and only if it's in
the max weight basis so far and it's
feasible to accept it ok so everything
about this algorithm is really simple
except for perhaps how do you how do you
choose this ordering okay so let me just
again give some examples of what this
ordering would look like so if the
feasibility constraints are at a uniform
mate Royd once s is chosen the span of
the heaviest element in s is just the
empty set because we don't span anything
the span of any set V is also the empty
set if the size of V is less than K but
as soon as we get a set of size K now
which span is the entire ground set okay
so the ordering that this algorithm
needs is actually just an arbitrary
order okay so with this algorithm would
look like for K uniform mate Royds is it
chooses this set randomly as described
and then the remaining elements can come
in an arbitrary order and the algorithm
will still work
okay here's a more combinatorial example
where okay so graphic may towards
remember the edges are the elements in a
cyclic sub graphs are feasible so once s
is chosen let's say that s is the
following four elements and i1 has the
heaviest weight then we're gonna process
the edges in the following order
so first we'll process any copies of the
edge a B because this has the because
the price of these elements is i1 the
weight of i1 then we'll process any
elements that form a cycle with I 1 and
I 2 so these are elements who have both
end points in the sets ABC because their
price is going to be i2 then we'll
process any edge with both end points in
a BCE because their price is going to be
I 3 and then we process the remaining
edges after
oh sorry so we get to choose the order
of the elements so when I say process I
mean pick that elements to be have its
weight revealed yeah sorry okay so any
other any questions about this so this
is again just to make clear what the
algorithm is doing I haven't tried to
give you any intuition as to why it's
good yet okay okay so now there's um I'm
gonna give you one observation and then
one proposition and then we'll prove
that the theorem works the algorithm
works okay so first let's observe that
element I is only accepted if its weight
exceeds its price with respect to s okay
so why is this well if it's not if it
doesn't exceed its price with respect to
s then it doesn't exceed its price with
respect to everything you've seen so far
and therefore it's not in the max weight
basis so far okay so we can only accept
elements that exceed their price with
respect to s okay and now I want to
reason the following I want to provide a
sufficient condition for it being
feasible to accept an element I so I'm
claiming that if the price of i with
respect to s is larger than the price of
i with respect to s bar minus i then it
will definitely be feasible to accept i
by the time we process it okay so why is
this so first by our choice of
processing elements in the algorithm all
j that are revealed before i have a
price with respect to s at least as
large as the price of i with respect to
s so that was our algorithms choice also
in order for any J to possibly be
accepted by this observation its weight
must be at least as large as its price
with respect to S
okay so therefore every element that is
processed before I and is accepted has
weight at least as large as the price of
i with respect to s that's just by
chaining these two together okay so now
if it's infeasible for us to accept I
what must have happened we must have
accepted a set of elements that span I
okay but if that happens then that means
that we have a set of elements all in s
bar minus I whose weight is all larger
than the price of i with respect to s
and this directly means that the price
of i with respect to s bar minus i is
larger than the price of vibe with
respect to s okay let me go through this
last sentence one more time so remember
that the price of i with respect to s
bar minus i means i start with the
heaviest element in s bar minus I and I
would keep going down and I stop when i
span i okay and we know that we can span
i using elements that are all heavier
than the price of i with respect to s so
that means that this process definitely
stops before we have considered any
elements with weight lower than the
price of vibe with respect to s this
directly means that the price of vibe
with respect to s bar minus i is at
least as large as this okay so this this
is actually really the key lemma and
driving the proof okay so now the rest
is just finishing up and showing that
basically that this happens with good
probability okay so here's the rest of
the proof so i is in s bar with
probability 1/2 that's by choice of s
independently the price of i with
respect to s is larger than the price of
i with respect to s bar minus i with
probability 1/2 and that's because of
how we chose s that s and s bar minus i
are equally likely to be flipped okay so
the price of i with respect to s is
larger than the price of i with respect
to s bar minus i with probability
exactly 1/2 and for any i in the true
max way basis it will definitely
we will definitely accept I whenever
both of these occur because this means
it's feasible to accept I when it
arrives and this means that I comes in s
bar so it's not part of this rejected
set and so this directly says that we
accept every element in the max weight
basis with probability at least 1/4 and
that gets the for approximation okay so
that's um you can ask there any
questions about this proof so I'm just
gonna say one sentence and then just
wrap up the talk okay cool so what is
the underlying technique here that might
generalize well so basically we showed
that you can couple good samples ones
that result in I getting I it being
feasible to accept I with bad samples
ones that result in it being infeasible
to accept I in a way so that whenever s
is bad then as far as good and that led
us bound the probability that it's
infeasible to accept I okay so um now
I'm gonna start summarizing and wrapping
up so what we saw was three different
algorithms we saw an e approximation for
K uniform mate roids and the main idea
behind this algorithm was that we found
a clever way to charge a different
element different element in the max
weight basis of the samples for
everything we accept and we did this in
a consistent way we saw a 2 e
approximation for graphic mate roids and
then excuse me the main idea was we made
stricter feasibility constraints that
decompose into much smaller and simpler
excuse-me subproblems and we also saw
this for approximation for mate roids in
the free order model and the main idea
was to try and couple these good events
with the bad events in a way to show
that the bad events don't happen too
often okay and again this is not
supposed to be an exhaustive list of
every high-level technique that can be
used to design secretary algorithms but
I do think it's a pretty good sample of
some of the good high-level ideas
okay and so again I want to do similar
to before just touch on a couple of
results in very related models so what
if the objective function isn't linear
in the weights so what if you're not
trying to maximize the sum of weights
but you have some sub modular set
function and your goal is to try and
maximize f of whatever set you accept ok
so there's been a ton of works showing
constant factor approximation x' for
various different kinds of Maitre
constraints and i want to point out one
of them separately there's recent work
of Feldman and nas inclusion that shows
a generic reduction from the sub modular
secretary problem to the linear
secretary problem so if you can design
good secretary problems for the linear
objective you can plug that into there
reduction and get a good secretary
algorithm for a Sabbagh Anisa modular
function as well okay here's another
change twist on the model is what if the
adversary gets to choose the weights and
the feasibility constraints but he
doesn't get to choose how the weights
are mapped to the elements okay so what
if the weights are randomly assigned to
the elements then in this case it makes
it harder for the adversary to generate
hard instances and in fact we know that
in this model for all mate roids there
is a constant factor approximation even
if the adversary gets to choose the
ordering okay so the point is that
really why the matrix secretary problem
is so difficult is exactly because the
algorithm can choose how to assign the
weights to the elements okay and another
question you might ask is what if the
ordering is not completely random okay
so we know that you need some randomness
to possibly get any bound that
completely worst-case ordering is
hopeless but it turns out that you
actually don't need all of the entropy
of a uniform random order in the single
choice case that actually like
exponentially less entropy suffices okay
this is just one slide of some of the
current directions that people are
studying and these problems so the the
obvious question
is um is there a constant factor
approximation for allmate roids in the
standard model okay and I'll point out
in my opinion I think the most
interesting special case that hasn't
been resolved yet are representable
matrix so here what I mean is pick your
favorite field is there a constant
factor approximation for the matrix
secretary problems for all vector spaces
over that field so this we don't know
the answer to yet and again if you don't
remember from the slide the best
approximation we know for general matrix
is the log of the log of the rank okay
also my own opinion is I I personally
get excited whenever we prove tight
approximations for any special cases and
currently we really only know this for
transversal mate roids we don't know a
tightiy approximation for graphic mate
roids for a laminar mate roids or for
all mate roids in the free order model
okay and also you know okay I think
depending on who you ask some people
believe that really the right answer for
all mate roids is e so maybe it's not
possible to prove a lower bound of
anything larger than e for arbitrary
policies but maybe there's some
interesting lower bounds proving say
that an algorithm certain kinds of
algorithms can't get a tight
approximation or maybe algorithms with
proofs that look like ones we saw can't
get any approximation okay so that's
everything I have thanks again